this is a Fox News Alert we have just
learned some Texas National Guard troops
are right now preparing to deploy to the
southern border as part of president
Trump's plan to secure the boundary with
Mexico also in the past few minutes
Arizona's Governor Doug Ducey says 150
of his state's National Guard members
will be sent to the border next week now
to a story we actually plan to bring you
the Defense Department is gearing up a
new unit to help deal with security
along that border national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin has the
latest from the Pentagon tonight
President Trump wants up to 4,000
National Guard troops sent to the Mexico
border as soon as possible but so far
the Pentagon can't offer a timeline as
to when those troops will deploy that
depends on the speed of state governors
and DHS the Pentagon announced it is
standing up a new planning cell man 24/7
effective immediately we are
establishing a new border security
support cell this is not business as
usual that cell met for the first time
today the president says US troops will
build part of the wall on military
border lands we're gonna have our wall
and we're gonna get it very strongly he
was referring to the Barry Goldwater
live fire range in southwest Arizona
which runs just 31 miles of the roughly
2,000 mile border and sees jets dropping
bombs daily Border Patrol officials
expect the military to be used in
support roles they'll be helping us sort
of the backroom activities we've used
them previously to help repair roads and
vehicles we've used them to do
intelligence and analysis for
intelligence when President Bush sent
six thousand guards to the border it
cost four hundred and fifteen million
dollars one Democratic governor made it
clear her forces would not be deploying
there's been
absolutely no planning there's been
absolutely no collaboration with the
states this is just something the
president reeled off to distract from
the problems that he's having in
Washington DC officials tell me it could
be two months before all the troops are
in place that's how long it takes to get
the bureaucracy moving Bret Jennifer
Griffin at the Pentagon Jennifer thank
you